[Music]
if you could wish for anything
delivery have a nice day delivery thank
you
what would it be hey lina happy birthday
i miss you oh no
oh gosh um
greetings great master the hands have
opened
oh a peasant boy well this will be easy
i know what you're thinking could this
be real is magic
real yes it's real
i am a wish who will grant three wishes
to the owner of this teapot
how do you fit in this teapot it's so
small look at your little arms
your face is so soft oh can you breathe
fire
now i've been stuck in this teapot
for a thousand years so the sooner we
can get this over with
the better
excellent choice you see her i wish stop
stop stop stop stop stop stop
i can't make people fall in love with
you no she's my best friend
ten years ago
[Music]
bye dan that's my wish i want my friend
back
[Music]
i'm going to need that teapot i wish i
knew how to fight
[Music]
i wish
[Music]
yes go ahead long i'm not gonna waste a
wish on traffic
look you're gonna have to use you're
gonna have to use
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to use it
if only i had a magical dragon that
could fly me across the city
[Music]
bye